bytes and molecules each living cell has
its own hard drive where it stores the
bytes of information needed to
function and grow adapt to
environmental changes and combat
dangerous centers information
store molecules that are organized into
sequences of letters what is known
as  dna code in the 1990s
a tremendous effort by governments
researchers and companies and/or
resulted in the complete sequence of the
human genome since then we have already
seen an exponential growth in
molecular data describing pse
in tissues organs and organisms large
assemblies  datasets contain
genetic information about healthy and sick young and old
are now freely available
to the public here we will
explore a few different types of
funny datasets as well as examples of the
data
containing ancestry-associated genomic variants
in gene expression levels
responsible for spread
cancer and protein modifications
can make important code
slow this course is intended for
all those interested in understanding
how the current
biometric data revolution impacts biomedical research
on human health
bytes
and molecules